well let's bring in a retired Air Vice
Marshall Shauna Bell for some analysis
on what's happening in Ukraine and let's
start off Sean if we can thanks for
being with us first of all on what may
be in that one billion pound package
yeah it's a significant uh additional
contribution I mean it's in comparison
it's dwarfed by the US's 40 billion
dollars but the UK is the second largest
contributor so it is significant the UK
state has been supplying 120 armored
vehicles uh over 5 000 end law and
attack weapons which have had such a
decisive effect and the multi-launch
rocket system shown here the latest
package is sophisticated air defense
systems it's also some drones our main
air vehicles which are the eyes and the
ears over the battlefield they can also
carry Munitions and therefore do
Precision strike they're talking about
electronic warfare they probably mean
things like GPS Jammers and stuff like
that and about thousands of additional
material probably clothing and stuff
like that
um but the weapons alone are no direct
use to the ukrainians they have to have
training for those weapons to make them
effective the UK has been training
Ukrainian fighters ever since 2015 and
over the last few weeks over 450
ukrainians Fighters have been out on
Wiltshire on the Salisbury Plain at
ranges learning how to use the weapons
that are being provided this is all
takes time which of course is at a
premium but of course it's a vital
ingredient for converting these high
technology equipment into credible
military capability yeah I've seen
learning how to use artillery pieces but
look at things they're fascinating stuff
okay now of course there's been a lot of
coverage recently about the amount of
money spent on defense spending Boris
Johnson has suggested today that the UCO
increases defense spending to 2.5 of GDP
above what NATO wants at two percent I
mean how significant an announcement is
that Sean do you think it's very
significant particularly because the
unrest and the different messages that
are coming out of the government as a
military man and clearly I welcome any
increase in defense spending um
particularly because it provides us a
more robust and reduce the risk but of
course the UK does contribute more than
the two percent uh buffer for NATO
and a significant majority of the other
NATO countries there's only a selection
shown here do not meet that two percent
margin as a UK taxpayer like you
um I we've got the biggest national debt
in this country we've had in a
generation NHS is a priority welfare
cost of living so there are other
priorities and I can understand why that
there are a variety of views about what
whether a defense is a priority once the
dust settles on all of this inevitably
the UK will conduct a defense review
there will be a review of our national
priorities and and and then decide where
defense sits interestingly though the
Prime Minister has announced a rise to
2.5 percent of GDP for NATO but he
specifically said by 2030 and what he's
done by that is buy some time for the
dust to settle in the meantime in the
near term of course NATO is a team sport
and membership of NATO carries
significant benefits and what we need to
see is those Nations that are no longer
not yet paying their premium paying up
yeah perhaps they will cough up the rest
they should be paying towards NATO and
fine let's look at the fighting on the
ground then because there's been some
activity around Snake Island that's of
course in the south in the uh just off
the city of odessa's we can see it there
and just tell us what's been happening
around snake island in the past few days
yeah it's not really been in the news
since the early days of the war it's 40
kilometers off off the coastline of
Ukraine made famous of course when the
muscular before it was sunk
um it threatens the Island's protectors
the Ukrainian protectors to give up and
the Ukrainian protectors famously in
colorful language told the Russians to
go away
um they were captured and Russia took
why is that important though because
it's a tiny Island the main reason is
valencian air from a maritime
perspective the Russians control a major
port of sevastopol and control the Black
Sea from a land perspective they now
control a lot of the coastline around
the the Black Sea but from an air
perspective Ukraine still has a lot of
control over that uh over that sea if
you were to put anti-aircraft missiles
on snake island that would have a
strategic consequences for the whole
region and as a result that's why Russia
have been trying to take it after Russia
invaded they've been desperately Keen to
try and to establish a military facility
there the trouble is when the musk was
sunk the Russian Navy moved South out of
the way and that's made it very
difficult for them to actually build
anything on the island and every time
they do the Ukraine has been very
effective conducting airstrikes and
wiping it out resulting in huge
casualties of Russians hasn't hit the
news because it's not been on our radar
effectively only a couple of days ago
the most recent facilities were
flattened Again by the ukrainians and as
a result the Russians have pulled out
now Putin claims he's not hampering the
Russians are not hampering the resupply
of grain and as a gesture of Goodwill
they're pulling their people out of here
ukrainians said it's a victory for us
now who knows what the truth is but the
island is shrouded in smoke at the
moment witnessing to some pretty major
battles and it's very hard to see that
this isn't a major strategic win for
Ukraine you're right okay Sean do
appreciate that analysis thank you so
much